Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
I'm gonna be talking about my recent trip.
I mean, so much happened
on my trip and on your trip
that we've decided to make it a-
Separate episode.
Separate episodes.
They're not two parts,
they're independent.
Independent.
We can vacate separately
and then update each other.
And I wanna say that, you know,
it wasn't my idea for me to go first.
And just before we got started,
you said, "You know what?
You should go first."
And I was like-
And then I said-
"I accept this."
But I want credit, you know?
So I'm gonna go first today
and talk about my trip.
I know what I'm gonna say.
I don't know what you're gonna
say 'cause I wasn't there,
so I'm a bit more interested in that.
Well, it's funny because yesterday,
well, I've been back for two days,
but yesterday was our first
day back in the studio
following the trip.
And Stevie came into our
office and as, as people do,
she said, "How was your trip?"
And of course I'm just
sitting in there with Link
and I'm like, "Well, I can't tell you
because I can't tell Link
'cause I have to tell
him on 'Ear Biscuits.'"
You could've asked me to step out, but.
It was such a weird thing.
And so then I was almost, I was just like,
"Well, so Stevie."
But it is my office.
"You could listen to this
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
to learn about my trip,
but I cannot tell you anything right now."
Oh, she falls asleep to
"Ear Biscuits" every night.
That's what she told me.
Well, it is boring at times,
especially when you know us very well.
People do do that though.
People will fall asleep-
Fall asleep to podcasts.
To "Ear Biscuits" specifically.
I feel like it's just our
soothing drone of conversation
that doesn't, I mean, it
rarely gets so enthusiastic
that it's like an alarm clock.
Well, I got something to wake you up.
I can encapsulate my trip in one visual,
and that is me being squirted
on by a penis water gun.
Okay.
Yeah, just get ready.
There's more where that came from.
Show it to me.
I do wanna, I've already talked
about the penis water gun,
but I do wanna say, you know,
this is probably not an episode
for the children to listen to.
I don't know, I don't know.
I know it's not gonna
be crazy, but I mean-
What do you mean, you've already talked
about the penis water gun.
Just then.
Oh.
I'm saying usually if like NPR would say-
Put a disclaimer.
This episode, if there are
little ones who listen,
they should not listen.
And I said penis water
gun before the disclaimer,
so I just apologize for that.
But there's more,
there's a good more than a
penis water gun that's coming.
So I don't get to see it right now
is what you're telling me?
Only if I can buy one.
I thought you said a picture.
No, what are you talking about, picture?
You said, "I have a picture."
Oh, I said a mental picture.
Oh crap, man.
It was like a visual.
But I mean, I'm sure you can
look one up on the internet.
It's just like a plastic penis
that has a trigger on it.
And a woman in a golf
cart squirted it on me.
A stranger? Have you
even said where you were?
I was at Key West.
I did say where I was, I
already said I was in Key West.
I think maybe I'm having
a listening problem.
Well, having?
I'm sitting, I'm doing
nothing but listening.
Yes.
What is Key West?
You have a listening problem.
Key West.
We've almost had an intervention
for this several times,
but we just keep getting by.
There's lots of Keys.
Kicking the can down the road.
Right.
So yeah-
But only one of them is Key West?
Key West-
Never been there.
Is the end of the line. I've
never been there as well.
I had preconceived ideas
about what Key West was.
I mean, geographically, this
is like the end of Florida.
I did not know that you can drive,
as my brother-in-law and sister-in-law did
'cause we were with Jessie's
sister and her husband.
They had driven all the way
from North Carolina to Key West,
and once you hit Miami,
you're still on a road
for 154 miles is what the sign said-
After Miami?
To get to the end of the line at Key West.
Would you have known that?
I had no idea that there's
just, I mean, 154 miles.
It's connected by bridges.
I didn't know that.
There's one section
that's a seven-mile bridge
over the ocean.
It used to be like-
Oh wow.
The longest bridge in America
or the world or something,
but it's not anymore.
It is still there though.
Is there like surf underneath you?
Surf?
Waves, are there waves?
This is the ocean.
I did not cross the bridge, I flew there.
Oh.
Yeah, I flew from Atlanta to Key West.
You can fly right into Key West.
It's just on one of those like small-
On a little plane?
No, interestingly, very small airport.
You know, I'm talking like
Burbank style airport,
just a few gates.
But there's a lot of folks
that wanna go to Key West.
So it was a normal size plane
and the island is two miles
wide and four miles long
or four miles wide, I
don't know the direction.
Direction is not something
that you're worried about
in Key West, first of all.
Like, where's north and
south? Nobody knows.
And that's not what's on people's minds.
I had these ideas about Key West.
I think one real prominent
sort of reputation
is that a Key West as is like Palm Springs
is a place where gay men like to go.
Anecdotally, I can
confirm that is the case.
Older men?
Gay men of all ages, but yeah.
But I do think that
the most, first of all,
but also all kinds of people.
I mean, it wasn't like 90% gay men.
It was also a lot of just men and women,
couples, people just of all ages,
but it is a little bit older clientele.
Well, my dad went there a
few weeks before you did.
So I'm like, okay,
I'm starting to develop
a clientele situation.
You got gay men.
And that makes sense to me.
And then you got my dad, who, you know,
spends a lot of his life on a golf cart
going around Myrtle Beach.
So if he's gonna go to another locale,
you've already mentioned a golf cart.
So I'm like, okay, this is
starting to add up for my dad.
Maybe not for you.
Yeah, well, it's quite a melting pot,
though most of the ingredients
in that melting pot are white.
I will say that, so it's
a very white melting pot.
Miami is not white.
No, no, no, no.
But I'm saying people
of all walks of life,
but just sort of mostly white.
But I gotta say, I had a good time.
It was a good trip as I will tell you.
Tell me.
Now, we originally,
now, my wife's sister and her husband
had been going to Key West for years
and always talking about how
much fun they have down there
and how we've gotta join them.
See, I thought that was
Costa Rica. Am I crazy?
Well, you have a listening problem,
and it is probably time
for an intervention.
So you're telling me that they never-
They had been to Costa Rica
and I have been to Costa Rica with them.
And they didn't wanna start a business
and move to Costa Rica permanently?
That was a separate, it
was a separate thing,
But it existed and I heard it. Ha, see?
Well, but no-
But since then they moved
onto Key West, which I never knew.
No, they're independent ventures.
And the Key West is a frequent,
in fact, they had already
been in Key West this year,
like a month ago.
Oh, okay.
Right?
Just a hop, skip, and a few states down.
Are they gay men?
No, no, a heterosexual couple, which-
Are they my dad?
As I was about to say,
there's a lot of that as well.
Okay, cool.
I will say that I did get,
I did one night I wore
my leopard print shorts
and I got a lot of compliments.
So they've been asking us to go down there
and you know how it is, man.
I mean, we just, we don't...
A lot of our travel is related to work,
and also over the past two years,
we haven't traveled much at all.
We had scheduled this
trip about a year ago
when no one knew what was
gonna happen with COVID.
And we're like, "Well,
where is it gonna be?"
And we scheduled it for late October,
right when it was actually
his birthday weekend.
And I was like,
"I really doubt that this
is actually gonna happen
because who knows what?"
And then when the Delta
wave started happening
and I was like, "Oh no, there's
no way we're gonna do this."
And then in talking to
Science Mike, he was like,
"Well, actually, in places like Florida,
the Delta wave is going to hit so hard
that it'll will have receded
significantly by that point."
And it's exactly what happened.
And especially in Key West,
the numbers were never
significant in Key West.
I don't know, something
about an island nation
where a lot of people are outside.
It's a nation?
You know,
it actually is a nation.
When you get off of the plane,
the airport says welcome
to the Conch Republic,
like conch like a conch shell because-
Can they say that?
There are no rules at this place.
You know, the whole what happens
in Vegas, stays in Vegas.
What happens on an island
stays on an island.
And I am convinced that there-
Even if you can get there via bridge?
Right, I think that there
is a deeply ingrained,
like thousands of like
millennia ingrained in humans
that like, "Hey, we're at this island,
we can do whatever we want to.
And what we do on this island...
Listen, as long as we don't
talk about it to anybody else,
no one's ever gonna
find out about, right?"
Now, modern life has complicated that
because of the bridge and the phones.
But I do get subconsciously,
I mean, it's of a size
that you felt like you
could see all of it in a day
or is it bigger than that?
Well, two by four miles, I mean.
Oh, okay, yeah.
It's mostly, there's like
a main strip in the middle,
which is, you know,
bars, restaurants, shops,
and then everything around
that is bunch of houses.
Very, very,
I would say like a Charleston
meets New Orleans vibe
in terms of like the architecture.
Like these beautiful old
Southern houses that are like,
I mean a lot of the properties,
you know like in Beaufort, North Carolina,
there's just like down by the
beach, those old wooden homes
of different colors?
Not on stilts?
Not on stilts.
That's strange,
I mean, with the amount of
hurricanes that come through.
And the thing that I was
thinking the whole time
is I was actually having
trouble like enjoying it,
knowing that, oh, the sea
level is rising and what's...
It was this weird thing
that was happening to me.
I was like, "Oh, this is beautiful,
but is it gonna be here in 100 years?
It's gonna be like Venus."
Don't get attached.
Because it literally feels
like, 'cause it's the truth,
that this place is just above sea level.
And all the sand is brought
in from The Bahamas.
There's no sand.
You might picture it like
this, like Caribbean island,
all a bunch of white sand.
Well, all the white sand is
brought in from The Bahamas
and it is actually like crushed coral
is what the actual surface of the sand is.
But most of it, like as
you go around the island,
the perimeter of the
island is like concrete,
like a wall, basically.
At some point they were like,
"We gotta stop this water."
Because I'm sure every
time a big storm comes in,
the whole place gets flooded.
But that didn't take away from the vibe.
I mean, we didn't go to the beach.
We went to the beach to like
eat at like some restaurants
that are like right on the
water, but there was no like,
"Hey, going into the ocean for a dip."
Huh.
But the specific weekend that
we were there was during...
But just so you know, I made the decision
that I felt like this was
a responsible decision
in light of where the numbers are at,
the fact that I'm vaccinated,
and the fact that we were gonna
be outside most of the time.
So that just to kind of
give you that piece of it.
But the specific weekend,
which again was predetermined
over like a year ago
because of Ashley's birthday,
happened to coincide with
something called Fantasy Fest.
Fantasy Fest.
I don't know the history of Fantasy Fest.
Right, let me guess what this might be.
I mean, so people go there in order to,
I don't know, just let it all hang out?
It doesn't seem like it would be,
that seems like-
Literally.
Seems like Key West is just a place
that is a fantasy fest.
What about this weekend is different?
I think it's just more of the same.
Okay.
Now, how do I put this?
During Fantasy Fest, and
according to Chris and Ashley,
my brother-in-law and sister-in-law,
this was an unusual amount
of the things that we saw
because of Fantasy Fest.
They were like, "This is not normal."
Okay, so the Fantasy did up its ante. How?
But during Fantasy Fest,
a light dusting of glitter on the breasts
is considered a shirt.
Oh, okay.
Can I just say that?
A light dusting of glitter.
Now, you can get a full paint job,
you can get just glitter, and
there are multiple stands.
Okay, what we would do,
the typical night would
be going out to eat.
First of all, great food.
I mean really, really, really good food.
Like I did not have a bad meal.
I was like, "Man!"
I mean, Chris and Ashley
have been down there
and they know the good spots,
so they were taking us to the good spots.
That goes a long way.
Man, I had so many good-
Are you sitting at dinner
eating a really good
meal and you look over
and there's somebody
wearing glitter for a shirt?
Hell yes.
Really?
Really.
You're dining. You've
been seated at a table.
This is not like order at the counter
and then put your number
at the table, this is-
No, this is fine dining.
This is, "Smoking or non?"
And by the way, with very few exceptions,
maybe one exception, we
ate outside the whole time.
No shirt-
We did outdoor dining.
No shoes, no service.
Sort of like
eating on the sidewalk.
Unless you have glitter.
And many of the...
So when you're on the
main drag, Duval Street,
which is like several blocks,
and it kind of has like,
you know, the main drag
and like Bourbon Street, or.
There's a number of places in America
that have this kind of vibe.
Bars, public drinking?
Yes.
And even though technically
public drinking is not allowed,
no one's following.
I also think being
topless except for glitter
is technically illegal,
but the cops are not
having a problem with it.
It's the Conch Republic. Conch?
I think conch.
Many of the restaurants and bars
had a bar on the perimeter
of the restaurant facing out,
so everybody would sit
looking at the sidewalk.
And the thing that I noticed
is that there were a
number of facilities that,
okay, this bar is a gay bar
and there's a drag show, right?
This bar is a gay bar
and this is a drag show,
but this bar is a bunch of
old heterosexual people.
You know, and it'll be like
right next to each other
and we were just going everywhere.
But the bars that were,
there was like these older
couples sitting there
on the benches looking out
and they would just both be
like not talking to each other,
and a pair of boobies would go by
and they would just both watch them
and then they would talk
to each other about them.
I sat there and watched the boobies pass
and then the people talk about it.
It's fascinating.
So there were that many
people just walking around with
their boobies flapping out,
boobaloobing it up with
just glitter or body paint.
More body paint than glitter.
I mean, were the nipples painted,
or like really glitter specific?
Depends on the person, man.
Wow, and what was the bottoms like?
Are we talking bikini bottoms?
Okay, well let me get
to that in one second,
'cause I'm not done with the boobies yet.
Yeah, don't leave the boobs
until you've fully explored them.
This is something that Jessie pointed out,
and I have to agree.
How pointy was it?
Well, I think that's my point.
In many cases, not very.
And she was like,
there is a big body positivity
thing happening in Key West.
It isn't like somebody's like,
"I have what is considered to be the."
Nicest rack.
"Perfect body
that would be an Instagram model."
It was like, "I have a body
and I have boobs and you're gonna see them
and I'm proud of that."
And it was just like, there
was something kind of beautiful
about just the level of freedom
that people just walked around with.
And again, according to the experts,
this is not every single day.
This is-
Fantasy Fest.
Fantasy Fest and then up to Halloween
is what I've been told, where
this is really concentrated.
But there's stands, right,
like you're walking down the street
and then there'll just be
a woman sitting in a chair,
completely topless, like pre glitter,
and then there's like another woman
with like an airbrush thing
and she's going in and doing the thing.
There's like a kid getting
face paint at the fair.
This is a topless woman
getting glitter or paint
on the street.
And then there's like another woman
just standing there topless
in line, waiting to go.
She's already taken her top off?
Just all ready to go, yes.
Interesting.
Are there kids walking
around ogling at this?
Very few, and the ones that were,
I was like, "This is, okay,
not trying to be judgmental here,
but I don't know if this is
appropriate for children."
They probably get over it
quickly enough, you know.
I mean most people have breastfed,
so putting a little glitter on there
shouldn't ruin anything.
I hate glitter until today, man.
Changed your view on glitter.
You asked about the bottoms.
You didn't ask about the men.
Now, that's where the bottoms
really come into play.
Yeah, I don't really
care about men's boobies.
Tell me about the men's boobies.
You care about the men's bottoms?
No, not really, but.
Well, I'm gonna tell you
about them because it, okay,
very common for a man to be
in nothing but a G-string.
And when I say a G-string,
like in the back, it's so
small that until you get close,
you just think he's nakey nakey.
Nakey nakey.
He's nakey.
You're speaking Rihanna now.
Nakey, nakey, nakey.
And there was one
and then there's a few
guys who go the extra mile
and have that situation-
A whole mile?
That when you turn to
the front, they have a,
one guy had a stocking that
was just around his junk
that went all the way down to
the ground and like dragged.
And I think he had a Santa hat on.
That's not what drag is.
No, no. He was literally
had something dragging.
Okay, so that's a Chili Peppers tube sock
taken to an extreme.
And if you can step on it,
then you're gonna lose
your sock pretty quick.
Well, it didn't drag all the time.
And so there's a lot and so
sometimes it's like a couple,
so there's a man who's dressed like that.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, okay.
Now it might be like a group of guys
who are presumably gay and
who are dressed like that.
But then also there's like,
this is a old man and his wife
and he's dressed like that
and she's dressed with the glitter boobs.
And then sometimes there's glitter boobs
and then the husband just
has on like a golf shirt
and he's not participating.
It's like dressing up for Halloween,
sometimes you go in together
and sometimes only one
person participates.
This is intriguing.
It's so fascinating.
A couple of questions.
I'm ready to answer.
Did you see any topless
glitterfied boobed women
who you could tell they were
just learning the ropes,
that they were kinda, they weren't-
You mean like the glitter
had a spotty pattern?
What do you mean?
No, that they were-
Like a home job?
They were trying it for the first time.
Like for me and the tube sock,
I would, I like the idea of walking around
in nothing but a tube sock, I do.
I sincerely am intrigued by that.
I would like to experience that.
I think there's a discount
tickets to Key West.
I'm gonna dog ear this conversation
for when I tell you about my vacation
and some things that I
learned about my own nudity.
Oh wow.
So we'll come back to that, but-
No, to answer your question-
I must say I'm intrigued,
but you know, is there someone who's like,
someone who goes to Key West,
did you think about wearing a tube sock?
Did Jessie thinking about going topless?
Was there a conversation here?
And if she would have gone
topless, it would have been-
There was a discussion.
Okay, so I wanna know about that,
and I wanna know if
she were to go topless,
there's an adjustment period of,
"Okay, I am gonna put my shoulders back
and I'm gonna own this."
I think you have to walk
down the side streets first,
because there's a lot of-
Did you notice any of that?
No, I didn't notice it at all.
I think people have practiced.
You know, that's weird to me.
It's like, where did they practice?
You didn't go on the side streets?
How do people work up to
being totally topless?
Well, I think you're
confused about something.
The Venn diagram between people
who are uncomfortable being naked
and people who got glitter on their boobs,
walking down the street in Key West,
like there's two distinct circles
that look like a pair of boobs.
You know what I'm saying?
Gotcha.
That's the Venn diagram and there's no-
You know what I like to do to boobs?
You like to push them
together, I understand that.
But the circles never cross.
They don't, they just get smooshed.
The boobs just get, they turn into ovals.
They never cross.
No one was uncomfortable and
that was a beautiful thing.
Now, there were people,
again, the average age of
the people walking around,
we're talking 40.
And so there's a lot of people over 40.
So that means that there
was the occasional younger,
you know, less gravity affected women
that would they drew a lot of attention.
And what I'm talking like 1 out of 10.
It would be like, "Oh, this
is just, this is a young woman
who's she's doing the glitter boob thing."
Or maybe she just got fished.
Lots of just fishnet, nothing under it.
That's another thing.
I could go on forever about this,
but I do wanna talk about other things.
She was caught by a trawler or something.
Yeah, well, there's a lot of fishing.
There's a big fishing industry down there.
And one of the things
that would happen then
is that people lock on to those.
Yeah.
There's a lot of-
See, that's double standards.
Is it oggling, ogling?
Ogling.
Ogling?
And there was a couple of times
where that made me feel
a little uncomfortable,
where I would be like kind of walking
and I would be behind somebody.
I go, okay, this is a younger lady
who's obviously I can tell
by the way people are looking at her
that she must be on display.
And like the dudes would just stop
and most everybody is intoxicated,
so there's just like this-
Open mouth.
Open mouth,
just following the boobs the whole time.
I was like, "Come on, man."
Chill out, you're on an island.
But last thing I'll say about this
before I move on to other things
is there was a discussion.
Not a realistic discussion.
Jessie wasn't about to do
this, but she did say one night
when we were just the two
of us were walking around,
so we had gone out to just the two of us.
I mean, we were spending
most of the time with Chris and Ashley
but there's one night
where we just kind of
went out on our own.
Yeah, that's the time.
Just give it a side street.
She was like, what would you...
She said, "What would you
do if I were to tell you
that I wanna go and get my boobs painted
and walk around like this."
And I would be like, and I said,
"I think I would probably
advise against it."
Hmm.
Okay, she said, "Well, first of all,
I would never do it because I just can't."
There's more than a seven-mile bridge
between her and her version of Jessie
that would walk around
topless in Key West, right?
It's just not who she is.
Yet.
It's not who she is right now.
But I said, "Well, honestly, it would."
Oh, here's another thing,
speaking of Venn diagrams,
the Venn diagram of Mythical Beasts
and people who vacation at Key West,
there's not a lot of
crossover there either,
which was a beautiful thing.
That's good, that's nice.
So, I mean, there's minimal recognition.
No pictures of you in just a sock
floating around on the
Mythical Society forums.
I think the people who've chosen
to be entertained by Key West,
like they don't need anything else.
They don't need internet stuff, man.
They don't need "Good Mythical Morning."
They don't need a couple of doofuses
eating weird stuff on the internet.
They got, I mean, you should
go there and you'll see.
Yeah, they've got glitter.
It seems like that's pretty much enough.
Because the thing I told her, I was like,
"I think the thing I would
be most concerned about
is like a picture of us getting taken."
Like I wouldn't, if you
really wanted to do that
and you wanted it to be your thing,
I'd be like, "More power to you."
But she was like, "So you're telling me
that if there was no way anyone,
like none of your fans,
none of our family,
no one would find out, you
would be like, 'Cool'?"
I'd be like, "Yeah, it'd
be fun, it'd be cool."
She would never do it, and I
wouldn't expect her to do it
and I would never pressure her to do it.
It's just, there's a certain
mentality that leads to that.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what path,
life path leads to
glitter boobs at Key West,
but there's quite a few
people who get to it.
It's freeing, man.
They all seem very happy.
And I'm intrigued.
Okay, I got more to talk about,
but do wanna take a second to
tell you about Black Friday.
Is that coming up already?
It is coming up, yeah.
Okay, if you wanna be the first to know
when our sale goes live,
all you gotta do is sign up for our email
and text notifications at mythical.com.
I'm trying to fight off a burp while I-
Just embrace it, man.
Did it sound like it?
Yeah it did.
Did it sound-
You should've just released it.
Like I was about to burp?
Black Friday.
Go to mythical.com.
If you sign up now,
you'll get a code for
10% off your first order.
And then you get a little text
notification, a little email.
We'll do it tastefully.
You know, Key West style.
Black Friday, mythical.com.
Get ready for it, text, email.
Before I move on to other
things, just to establish,
I really, really, really,
really like Key West.
Boobs. Oh.
Yes, okay.
And I plan to go back.
Wow.
Not because of the glitter, again-
I'm still a little surprised
by that. I don't know.
No, here's the thing.
You know how like-
The way you describe it,
because like-
No.
I didn't love Bourbon Street.
I don't like those, the
party streets and the bars
and like the people
retching into the culverts.
There wasn't a whole lot.
I didn't see any retching.
I did see like just a
pile of vomit somewhere.
Did the glitter boobs cover a world
of your normal taste?
No, no, no.
I also wanna say that it wasn't just like-
You Jimmy Buffett all of a sudden?
Every time we're going out,
it's just like glitter boobs,
glitter boobs, glitter boobs,
and that's the only thing
you're thinking about.
You've seen one set of glitter boobs,
you've seen them all, kinda.
But there's live music,
there's a bunch of people playing like,
a lot of people playing country music.
And the architecture of the whole place.
I'm saying like, during the
day we ride our bikes around.
I'm reading between the lines,
but you haven't talked
about being inebriated
the whole time,
so that would help with clarity.
Was I inebriated the whole time
or if I haven't talked
about a being inebriated
the whole time we've
been doing this podcast?
A. Is that a factor in your enjoyment?
Like island life, you know?
♪ I stepped on a pop top ♪
Well, I didn't, I mean,
I didn't drink every single night
because when I drink every single night,
multiple nights in a row,
I start getting like
psoriasis popping up on my face and stuff.
So I have to kind of like watch that.
And honestly walking around-
I'm no Cindy Lauper, but I get it.
With a few drinks or no
drinks at all wasn't that,
I just don't, I don't do that.
I don't get like,
"Oh man, that guy's not
gonna make it home," drunk.
I just don't do that.
So this is
a sober assessment, go ahead.
I'm talking about the island itself.
The island has been there
for hundreds of years.
I love, it's my favorite type of house.
Like, I mean, this is
where like Ernest Hemingway
had a house that you can tour.
This is where Harry Truman
had his little white house
that he would go to,
which was like this
beautiful piece of property
that he would go to convalesce
from being sick of different things.
And there's all these historic houses.
And then you just take a,
you get off on the main drag
and there's these beautiful
beach houses that, again,
these things have been
there for a very long time.
Every single building, every single home,
is very, very old and everything
just has so much character.
And then like, it's that classic
like Caribbean vegetation,
where there's just so much
plant life everywhere.
And you just feel like I could
go down this little alley
and there'll be like a weird
house here and a weird house,
nooks and crannies.
I've talked about how much I
love New York City and London
because of the nooks and crannies.
The island version of nooks
and crannies is Key West.
And so the vibe, I kept
saying it over and over again,
the first night I was
like, "I love the vibe."
And I hadn't seen a pair of titties yet.
I was just like, "I love
the vibe of this place."
Not even one peaking around the corner?
Nothing.
And Jessie was like, "Oh, well
I knew you'd love this place
because of the way that it."
She's never been there,
but just the way it had been described.
And of course I love to
eat and I love good food.
And we started off right
after I got off the plane
and started with a really good meal.
And the company was great,
we had a great time hanging
out with Chris and Ashley,
hadn't seen them, you know, in a while,
hadn't been just the four of
us hanging out in a while.
So my sober assessment
of Key West is that,
yes, if you're gonna
lean into the partying,
that's a certain personality.
That's not me, I'm a people watcher.
So I'm gonna go have a good
meal, have a few cocktails,
and then I'm gonna walk
up and down the street
and we're just gonna talk about it.
There is a little bit of an element
of like feeling like
this isn't who we are.
Like, we're a little
bit separated from this.
It's kind of like going to
a zoo and just watching,
you know what I'm saying?
There's this sort of sense
of separation from it.
And hopefully not, I don't think judgment,
but it's just like
we're not gonna do that,
we're not gonna break it out,
I'm not gonna wear a G-string,
she's not gonna put the glitter boobs on.
But we had a great time.
It's a beautiful place and
best explored on bike, okay?
Or golf cart?
There's lots of golf carts,
but Chris and Ashley are
really into the bicycles.
Now, they had driven down with
bicycles on top of their car.
On top of their car, okay.
And then they got nice bikes.
Like Chris has this, I don't
know how much it costs,
it's a really nice-
Not an e-bike, is it?
It's not an e-bike, but
it kind of has that vibe.
It's got like a button on the handle bar
to lower and raise the
seat while you're going
for different modes.
It's a beautiful like carbon
fiber bike. It's awesome.
Does it have a big seat?
Is it a street bike or a mountain bike?
Oh, it's got a big seat.
You gotta be comfortable.
And then Ashley has-
It's called a dropper post, by the way.
Okay, I don't know about the bike terms.
Ashley has-
Very, very useful in mountain bikes.
Like one of these-
For going on a Key West adventure,
I know not why you need it.
She has-
It's just if you were sized differently.
A very, you know, I don't
wanna say Pee-wee Herman,
but you know what I'm saying.
Like one of those bikes
that's got the wheel covers
and it's painted and it's
got like a design on it.
And it's kinda, it's a woman's bike.
It's funny that I've never
seen those type of bikes
on top of a car.
You know when bikes are on top of a car
and they're facing the
same direction as the car
that these people are
serious about their bikes.
And then when you look up
at the particular bike,
you don't expect to see
a Pee-wee Herman bike,
but here we are.
I mean, you can be serious about it.
But you know what I'm saying.
Like a really nice beach cruiser.
Top of the line beach
cruiser. Yeah, I get it.
But like painted in like
it was like an aqua,
there's like flowers or something.
I don't know, it's another,
this is an investment.
These are in different
types of investments,
but both, they're into the bikes.
You had to rent bikes
to tag along, I guess?
Chris had handled it.
He had the bikes rented
and locked up at our hotel ready to go.
They were very excited
about the bike exploration
of the island.
Now, I don't know if you've met my wife.
I don't know that I've
ever seen her on a bike.
I will say that.
Well, if you haven't met Jessie on a bike,
you haven't really met Jessie.
Good Lord.
So she did not fall. There
was a couple of moments.
There was a couple of very
close moments, and of course-
Hey, I know exactly how
the joking went like.
You know, you were
trying to set up the fact
that like everybody get ready
and then she probably got a
little angry with your ribbing.
Well...
And then she got on the
bike there was no hiding.
Here's the thing.
And I don't advise this and I'm
not necessarily proud of it,
but we didn't wear helmets
because helmets do not exist in Key West.
Like I think it might be
against the law to wear helmets
in Key West when on bike.
Maybe a shirt too.
Yeah, and so I wasn't,
again, I don't recommend it,
but I take my own
responsibility for my own life.
And when in Key West, I don't
wear a helmet when I bike.
And also you get dressed
up to go to dinner.
And for Jessie, that
means dress and heels.
Oh.
Now, Ashley has some
like technique for like,
she gets her heels like,
here's the pedal and
then here's the high heel
and she'd like grips it like a claw.
That's how cowboy boots
were originally designed
to go in a stirrup that same way.
Yeah, and she's got it figured out,
but Jessie had not figured this out.
And also the thing about Jessie is
both Jessie and I tend
to be rule followers.
Jessie tends to be maybe a little bit more
of a rule follower than me.
When I'm on a bike, I'm like,
yeah, I know that the traffic
laws technically apply to me,
but I'm on an island and
it's Key West and who cares?
And so there's a stop.
I'm not gonna stop at the
stop sign if I don't need to.
And hey, this is a red
light, but nobody's coming.
Now, and Chris and Ashley and
I are all on the same page.
There's a lot of like coming up to a light
and seeing that nobody's coming
and just going through it.
There's just nobody,
there's no cars, right?
But Jessie would get, she would get mad
when we got to a light
and we just kept going.
It led to some fights, right?
And then she was also like,
"I'm not comfortable on the bike."
Course, you weren't there for the fight
'cause she was still
back at the red light.
Yeah, and she's like,
"I'm not comfortable if
we're gonna drive to dinner
and I'm gonna have a couple of cocktails.
I'm not comfortable on
the bike to begin with,
and then you want me to drive
back in my dress and my heels
after a couple of cocktails
without a helmet?"
She had a point.
She's gonna have to take the dress off,
put on some glitter to get back home.
She'll get there, don't worry about it.
We ended up modifying
the bike plan for Jessie.
Oh, I thought you were gonna say,
"We ended up modifying the bike."
Yeah, we created a flotilla of bikes.
It's more like a car.
We put her in a wagon, like one of those-
We did talk about renting the golf cart
because the golf carts, I
mean, the golf cart's so great.
I haven't seen your dad's down
in Myrtle Beach, but like-
Oh, I showed you the picture. life.
But like can his fit six people?
No.
Like two rows
and then one facing the back?
No, his doesn't have that second row.
It just has a back facing.
Most of the ones in Key West
have capacity for six or
as many as can hold on.
Plus very loud speakers,
which is another thing.
Yeah, he's got that.
You gotta, and Chris and Ashley were on,
they were ready for this.
They have a speaker
that Ashley puts in the front of her bike
and they have a playlist that's got,
I mean, it goes everywhere,
but it goes everywhere with us
and we bring the music
to wherever they go.
♪ Wasting away again ♪
Like that?
No.
They have sort of like a
Latin flare to the music.
♪ Ole, ole ♪
Yeah, I mean-
Toyota.
You know, like Pitbull is kinda like a...
Pitbull and everything
surrounding Pitbull.
Chris and Ashley, they
can pump some Pitbull.
Like I can't see you and
Jessie pumping some Pitbull.
The funny thing is-
Volitionally.
I don't know what it
comes from, but I have a,
I don't like to impose
myself in places, right?
I don't know what it is, a lot
of tall guys have this thing
where like we're a little bit hunched
and we're trying to make
ourselves a little bit smaller.
We don't like to draw
attention to ourselves.
So the idea of having a speaker
that's bringing the party wherever we go.
Now, first of all, very common down there,
but that took a little
bit of an adjustment,
but eventually I just realized
that we would go by people
and everybody would be like,
they immediately began dancing to it.
Start dancing?
Oh, you were like fireball.
And I was like, "We are
doing the right thing.
They've got this figured out."
Yeah, they've done the reconnaissance.
But we did not have a pirate ship.
There was a pirate ship
on the second night.
I didn't expect you to.
We're walking up and down,
and then all of a sudden hear
the loudest music possible
getting closer to us.
And then I look and there is
a float that is a pirate ship.
Like a parade float?
Like a parade float, but a pirate ship
that goes all the way down to
the ground like a low rider.
You couldn't even see the wheels.
It would look like a pirate
ship just sliding down the road.
And then it has the masts of the ship
are basically stripper poles.
Let's just be honest.
Perfect.
And I'm showing you a
video of that right now.
You'll have to watch
the video version, Link,
for you to see this 'cause I filmed it.
We actually followed it.
And there's just this old dude.
He's the only one up there dancing.
And then there's several old couples
who were back in the
back kind of driving it.
And the funny thing is,
is they went past and Chris was like,
"That might be the chamber of commerce."
Like he wasn't joking.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's what we're dealing with.
Could you get on board and do a dance?
We thought about it.
Was that
what was gonna happen
later in the evening?
Well, every stoplight more
women got on, eventually.
Oh.
And I mean-
Wow.
Let me see.
Fantasy land.
I'm talking, Fantasy Fest.
I'm talking about like a 65-year-old man
with a ship's wheel is how
he's controlling this thing.
Damn, he was really
steering with that shit?
Yes.
Oh God.
And there's all these people in the back
who were in the age range
and they are blaring "WAP"
as loud as you possibly can imagine.
And there's just like old guy
who's just like dancing to it.
Everybody is stopping and filming it
because it's so awesome.
Yeah. "We are pirates!"
That's what it stands for.
Okay, so we got through the bike thing,
but then we experienced
the test of every marriage
and that is double kayaking.
Oh God, yes it is. That's it, isn't it?
It is.
Like I remember Kevin
talking about his honeymoon to New Zealand
and they almost died on a double kayak
because they were about
to kill each other.
If you wanna know if your
marriage is gonna last,
rent a double kayak
and go on a kayak tour.
And the way you know it doesn't last
is you kill each other.
We've done this before,
we did it in Hawaii,
and then now we did it in Key West.
And we were gonna go
through the mangroves.
Now, first of all, there's
this beautiful mangrove.
These are trees that grow in the ocean?
They're the ones that are
like, they're on these islands,
but they're kind of in the ocean as well
and they shoot these roots
down just into the water
and pull up the water.
And they're like a environmental barrier
for all kinds of stuff.
And it's also like a nesting
area for all these sharks
and nurse sharks and crabs and all this.
So we went on like an eco tour.
Also in the Everglades, I think.
I think so.
I mean, mangroves are all over the world
in coastal locations, but.
That sounds cool though.
There was tunnels like
these mangrove tunnels
and we would go through the tunnels
because you know, like these channels,
these tide channels that
you could go through.
And I was just thinking,
"Man, I remember in Hawaii
where there were some tense moments."
And I was like, I go in thinking,
"I want my own kayak
and I want Jessie to have her own kayak."
And then we'd get in line
with the other people who are there,
and the woman is like,
"If you can, please,
if you have a partner, please
get into a double kayak.
That is what we prefer."
And I'm like, "Damn it, okay."
And we get into the-
It increases the chances
of at least one person
being able to get you back
from wherever-
I get in the kayak
and I say, "I'm gonna be
in the back," you know?
And I'm like, "Just as a reminder."
And the moment that I
began talking like this,
it feels very mansplainy to my wife.
But it's not of course.
But, well, I mean, I've been on kayak.
I've been on kayaks a lot, right?
And so I'm just like, "So I'm
gonna be the, I'm the rudder,
I'll be the one who turns us.
You just be the motor and
I'm gonna take your lead.
You take the lead in terms of the pace,
because I can see you, you can't see me.
And I just want you to naturally
just go right and left.
And when you need to
paddle, I'll let you know.
And when you can stop, you can just stop.
And for a lot of this,
you probably won't even need to paddle."
And I can immediately, even
though I can't see her face,
I know that I've already started
this off on the wrong foot,
but I'm just trying to
establish some kind of system
for us to enjoy.
And you sweetened the deal
by seeming like you're doing a favor.
"I can do this all on my own."
And what I learned in
a short period of time
is that the double kayak
experience with your spouse
is a great analogy for
marriage in general.
Because first of all,
you gotta stay in sync.
You got to know your roles
and I'm not talking about like,
you know, traditional roles.
I'm just saying that like,
you're dividing responsibilities
in some way that you've
mutually agreed upon.
There is communication that is important.
Yeah, and you give your wife a stick
so that she can bludgeon you with it.
Right, now I have to say that
I believe that my marriage
is significantly healthier than
our double kayak experience.
There was no, she didn't hit me,
I don't even believe that
we cursed at each other,
but there was a number
of times when I was like,
"Jessie, stop paddling.
Like I told you, you
don't have to paddle."
'Cause I'm trying not to be the guy
who's yelling at his wife.
And we're in a group, so I'm kind of just,
just so she can hear me, like,
"You can stop paddling now."
And then she's like, "Well, you're not."
Yeah, but if I stop paddling,
we're hitting this thing
or we're doing it wrong.
We're about to hit them.
She always thinks that
we're about to hit somebody.
It was like, I'm like,
"No, we're gonna go next to that person."
"Well, it seemed like
we were gonna ram them."
There was a lot of that.
We did get through it,
we did get through it.
We literally got through the mangroves
and we got through without
getting mad at each other.
I got to know some people.
And that's really cool,
I've got some great video
of us kind of going through those tunnels
which you probably already have seen.
Did you think about putting
the argument on Instagram?
Because it's like, it's one
thing to put the pictures,
but like, I think that's really
where we're at as a society.
We got to start putting
our shit on Instagram.
No, I didn't.
I really like the like Instagram
photo versus real life.
I'm a fan of that. Tempers expectations.
I didn't put any of this on Instagram.
I did notice that when I am
out doing something like this,
I'm actually thinking
more about the podcast
than I am about my social media.
Whether that's strategic or not.
Yeah, I get that.
I'm like, "I'm gonna take a video
and I'm gonna take it landscape."
All my video, most of it is landscape
because I'm thinking about
the presentation on YouTube,
on the video version of "Ear Biscuits."
Well, to take up for us,
I do think that it
compartmentalizes it in a way
that's a lot less,
it takes a lot less effort
to just think about something
and shoot a little something
that you want for yourself
that you might share with
people in this context later,
than sharing something in the moment
and then you're drawn into the comments
and the reaction to it and all of that.
It's like, I think it's not
pure, but it's a better choice.
Yeah, and I'm just not, I
just, the whole idea of like,
"I'm gonna capture this, this and this.
I'm gonna put it in like a photo dump."
I just can't get there, I
don't know if I ever will,
and that's fine.
It's fine.
I wanna tell you a really
cool thing that I brought.
I have a visual aid,
a little show and tell I'm gonna show you.
So one of the nights
we're going up and down,
taking in all the sights.
We also did like a little
self, I highly recommend this,
self-guided food tour
like during the middle of one of the days.
Chris and Ashley, they were like,
"Oh, there's this great Cuban place
that does a really great burger.
Oh, and there's this on
the water that does."
Oh, so they set up the
tour, Chris and Ashley?
No, they were like, "We're
going to bike to the places
that we think we should get things."
But it wasn't like, there was no itinerary
set by somebody else.
Self-guided.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You didn't download a PDF.
And the funny thing is,
is I've done this two
times in the last month/
When Shepherd and I
went to the Grove in LA,
I was like, "Let's not
just eat at one place.
Let's get a little thing
at like four places."
Yeah, that's cool.
This self-guided food tour is,
I think it might be my new thing.
But we did this there,
we got this lobster pizza
and then this lobster roll.
Shout out to the guy who worked
at the lobster roll place
who was a huge Mythical Beast.
So there was one.
And he's like,
"Dude, I've been watching you forever.
I have the Mythical shoes."
So like, he's, you know.
Wow.
So there were a few of
the younger set that I met
that knew who we were.
Anyway, ate a bunch of stuff.
Oh, and then Key lime.
So I didn't know, I'm from South Georgia
and I didn't know that like Key limes
are like the Florida Keys.
Like it's a lime that
comes from that place.
And Key lime pie is the thing down there.
And there's all these Key lime shops
and there's Key lime pie on
every single dessert menu
and like Key lime pancakes,
so Key lime everything.
And I love Key lime, it's
top three favorite desserts,
maybe number one.
Are they smaller?
Well, there's a place.
More Floridian?
There's a place where you
can get a Key lime pie
on a stick that's dipped in chocolate.
And that was the end of the food tour,
self-guided food tour.
I mean, it doesn't get
any better than that.
I actually had to call my mom after that
because she loves Key lime pie.
Oh, were you crying?
A little bit,
a little teary-eyed.
"Mom."
But one night we're walking down-
So did you eat the stick?
What it says on the stick.
Walking down the street
and I see a guy selling his
art on the side of the street.
And he's currently doing his art as well
in his pen and ink,
which I have discovered this about myself
in the past 12 to 18 months,
that I'm a huge pen and ink art guy.
I don't know what it is, but-
Key lime goes with pen and ink.
Something about the level of detail.
Okay.
I've always been into people
just doing this incredible detail
in a relatively small
space with just a pen.
I also think you're just as into
realizing you're into something
as you are being into it,
which is a double cool.
Well, no, because I could,
there's a number of different
arts that I could...
You're right about that,
but I'm saying there's something
specific about pen and ink
that I was like, "Oh, I
actually am a huge fan of this."
You know, I do the
little thing where I do,
I haven't done it in years,
but I do like the little
like mechanical drawings
with a pen and with pencil.
You've seen, I haven't done it in years,
but I do like these little intricate
little mechanical drawings
of like the system
and the pipes and the stuff.
I don't know if you've even seen-
Like "Buddy System" season one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I do that
kind of thing to kill time
but I don't do it recently.
I haven't done it recently.
And so I see this guy doing
this incredible pen and ink,
and then he's got his
prints that he's selling.
And I start talking to him,
I'm gonna tell you about
Daniel Linehan, okay?
Linehand?
Linehan with no D.
And this is a guy who has set up,
now first of all, we're
talking to him and like,
Jessie's like, "Oh,
you're gonna love this."
And we start going through his prints
and I'm like, "Oh man,
I'm gonna leave with
at least one of these."
And you know, and he sells
them for like 50 bucks a pop,
it's a print and I'll
show you the ones I got.
Which is a great deal for a print
on something that's this detailed.
So he begins kind of telling his story
and he's like, "You
know the van over there,
the Sharpie van?"
We're like, "Yeah, we've
been looking at it all week."
He's like, "Yeah, I made that."
So let me show you this guy.
Sharpie van.
So 2015-
Like the marker Sharpie?
2016, this guy took a van.
Oh wow.
And hand drew-
In Sharpie.
It's kind of hard to see just
how it had different colors.
Like the closer you get,
like there's incredible
detail in every single panel.
And he started drawing on
this van and then he's-
It's like full sleeve of tattoo,
but it's a van, not an arm.
But listen to his story.
So I'm gonna read, 'cause
this is an article from-
This is gonna be great for
people to fall asleep to.
fikeysnews.com, oh, Florida Keys News.
Florida Keys, flkeysnews.com.
Fikey, fikey.
One of my favorite websites.
And so as this is his story
which he ended up telling me
as I sat there and talked to him.
So this guy is, and he's older and so-
Use an older voice.
He's probably about 60
years old at this point.
But what is he? I wanna get to
the part where he says, okay.
'Cause he told me-
Can you use his voice?
No, that's an article.
Can use an older voice.
I'll use an older voice,
but just as somebody
who lives in Florida
Keys reading the paper.
"Linehan recalls walking
with a friend in Fort Myers
when they came upon a
young woman savagely."
Hold on, hold on, I was
hoping for it to be-
"Linehan recalls walking."
No, just a little more like,
"Ooh, like this is dramatic."
"Linehan recalls walking
with a friend in Fort Myers
when they came upon a young woman
savagely beating another young woman
while a group of men stood guard
to ensure the assault wasn't interrupted.
He said he intervened and
managed to separate the victim
who had lost consciousness
from her assailant,
only to be jumped by four men who beat him
so that he required hospitalization
and was left with permanent
damage in his right eye."
Oh God.
"'I don't regret it,' Linehan said.
My own mother said, 'Why
did you help that girl?'
'It could have been her or my daughter.'"
Is what he said.
Yeah, that was his answer.
This is the thing.
"The day his eyepatch came
off, Linehan said he went home
and sketched the Last Supper
all in free hand in black ink.
He keeps a print in his van
along with a portfolio of his drawings."
Now, this guy had not drawn,
which is the thing that the article,
the Florida Keys News need to
work on their backstory, but.
If he had never been an artist before,
that is a key point.
He had not drawn in 30 years.
Oh.
And he has this near death experience.
He wakes up, he takes off the eyepatch.
He can basically only see in
one eye and he sketches out
this incredible hand-drawn
Last Supper picture,
and then he just moves on.
And I'll show you the ones that
I ended up getting from him.
The dude's a freaking hero.
Oh wow. Look at this.
Oh, this is upside down.
"Wormhole Substation."
Now, here's what I wanna
tell you about this guy.
That's what it's called.
He does not use any,
no reference, no ruler.
It's all completely free hand.
Like where this is in the
middle of the page is all,
this line right here,
all this stuff is just
completely free hand
and just with a pen.
And then this is another one.
Just let me explain this, the
wormhole station for people.
Okay, so it's some futuristic looking,
I mean, there's rail cars like subway cars
wrapping around this thing
that kind of looks like a space station,
but it's very cushiony
looking and there's people,
yeah, like weightless astronauts
like tending to things.
And there's like little one man
helicopter things that are
floating around everywhere.
It's very fantastical, very fantasy land.
And they're all very, very different.
Like this next one-
This one is an outdoor scene
with mountains and forests.
And it still has a train,
but it's going across this
amazingly detailed bridge
from one tunnel on the right
into the other tunnel on the left.
It's hard to communicate how
long this takes somebody.
And also he was talking
about how he's like,
"I don't look at any other
artist's work, I don't."
'Cause Jessie was like,
"Do you have a website?"
He was like, "No, I don't do social media.
I got no website."
He's like, "This is my
website, me on Duval Street."
He said, "This is my website"?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He basically was like,
this guy has detached from the internet
and is out there drawing
this stuff on the street
and selling the prints.
This is the stuff that
I'm into, I just love.
I'm gonna have to put both of these up
in my office at the creative house.
Oh, I thought this was for me.
No, I didn't get you any.
You can come into my room anytime.
I really liked this one.
Yeah, but I've never heard you say
that you're into pen and ink.
You can, you know what?
You can take a picture of it
and look at it on your
phone anytime you want.
Can I make a print of the print?
No, I'll charge you $50 for that.
Maybe 60 to help with the tip.
It's mesmerizing. It almost
makes me feel relaxed.
But I gotta say, if you are down there,
and there's a lot of things to see.
Like I said, I mean, glitter
boobies are one thing.
He is his own website.
But he's just living the life down there,
drawing these incredible...
I mean, he was working on
one that was a playing card
and it was a king and a queen
and he had done one and
he was doing the next one.
And I saw him for like three nights,
'cause first night I hung out
for a little bit and got his story.
And then actually somebody,
two, it was interesting,
two different sets of people came up
and were big fans of the show
while I was buying this stuff.
And so he was like, "Well,
I finished my story,
but now I gotta hear yours
and why these people
are coming up to you."
"Well, my website is a real website."
And so then he wrote, 'cause
this man only works with pen,
he wrote down Rhett and Link on his palm.
On his palm?
And then the next night he chases me down
and he's like, "I saw."
He does go on the internet,
just so you know, he gets on the internet,
he just doesn't have his own website.
Well, he does but that's it, in person.
There is a Daniel Linehan
who is an artist in Texas.
Not him?
Different guy
who does have a website by the way.
Screw him.
Different guy,
not a pen and ink guy.
So he chases me out and he said,
"Oh, I checked it out, I love it."
"Checked it out, I love it."
So a shout out to Daniel Linehan,
if you're in Key West, go
by there, check out his art.
Support independent art,
about as independent as you can get.
Now, a couple of closing stories.
One of the things that happened-
I gotta go to Key West, homie.
Oh well, if you can ride a bike.
I mean, my dad's already been.
I would love to go to
Key West with your dad.
Good Lord, that would be awesome.
So I don't get a print
and now you've just invited my dad to go
after I'd just said I want to go.
Okay, cool, I get it.
I get it, we need to have our own things.
Walking down the street, as
I did over and over again,
and I looked like this, right?
I'm a big guy and I've got a beard
and I've got hair like this.
And there's a lot of drunk people
who would just say the first
thing that comes to their mind.
And at least two people said, "Jesus!"
Are you serious? Are you serious?
Yeah, right, yeah.
And they weren't, it
was not as an expletive,
they thought I was Jesus.
Maybe Mormon Jesus, I don't know.
You know, like really, really
white Jesus. So that was fun.
This is going in the con
column for Key West for me.
But the best thing that happened was
lots of people dressed up
like different characters
because they're going, not
just glitter boobs and thongs,
but people dressed up as characters
because they're getting
ready for Halloween.
It's like 10 days to
Halloween, let's get started.
And there's a guy clearly
dressed as Jack Sparrow.
And he was either actually
drunk, seemed very drunk,
or he was just a great actor,
like Johnny Depp level acting drunk.
But the way he addressed
me and what he said to me
makes me think that he was actually drunk
because he saw me from a
distance and came up to me
and he was like,
"Mimosa, Jason Mimosa!"
Jason Mimosa, like the drink!
The drink!
I mean that is the perfect thing
for Jack Sparrow to say in modern times,
to you, I guess.
But the thing is,
is he was not joking.
Jason Mimosa.
He wasn't joking. He had
had a few mimosas himself.
And he has now given me my alter ego.
I'm not Jason Mamoa,
I'm Jason Mimosa, man.
You know, I'm the-
That is, yeah,
that is much more accurate.
I'm the wish.com version of Jason Mamoa.
Now, by the time this airs,
you'll know whether or
not we pulled it off.
But as soon as this guy
called me Jason Mimosa,
that was when, you know,
Jessie and Chris and Ashley were like,
"Well, you got your
Halloween costume now."
And we're like, "What are we gonna do,
is Jessie gonna be a champagne
glass and she's just with me?
Is she like a brunch mom?"
I don't know how the costume
is gonna come together.
You'll know now.
It might be on my Instagram
if I figure it out.
But that was a highlight was
being called Jason Mimosa.
And then final story has
nothing to do with Key West,
but it is a story that
was communicated to me
while I was in Key West.
And it was the biggest laugh that we got
while we were in Key West.
And I do wanna premise this with the fact
that we had had a couple of cocktails.
So you're in a completely sober state,
so you can be the judge
of how funny this is.
I'm never in a completely
sober state, Rhett.
That's no way to be.
Chris is, he's got a guy
who's working on his house,
doing some kind of repair.
And he's getting to talk to the guy
and somehow he ends up finding,
the guy ends up saying how old he was.
60, 65, something like that.
And Chris is like, "Wow, you
look really good for your age.
What's your secret?"
And he leaned in and said,
with no sarcasm or irony at all, he said,
"I eat pussy everyday."
Are you serious? What?
Yeah.
Oh God.
So that really spoke to me,
and it gives me something to live up to.
Fountain of youth, huh?
Yeah, so apparently-
A real puss to lay on.
So anecdotally,
that is the way to keep
that skin looking young.
Hey, the dude is not joking.
It's like a really,
it sounds like the kind of thing, like a-
Fountain of youth.
A guy would say as a joke, but he was,
I was like, "Did he?"
Every day, huh?
And he laughed and Chris
was like, "No, he didn't."
And then because he didn't
laugh, Chris was like,
I don't know what the
follow-up to it was, but.
I think it's, "Oh, so
you're a cat person."
When you're at dinner in Key West
and you've had a few cocktails
and somebody tells that story,
you laugh an embarrassing
amount, but it doesn't matter
'cause you're in Key West.
You know what I like?
That's the wonderful thing about it.
I'm starting to pride
myself on being the person
in public places who's
having the most fun.
Like there's nothing wrong
with laughing the loudest.
Everybody just gets jealous. I love that.
You're actively doing this?
It's happened a few times
and I'm like, it's great.
It's great knowing that
you're having the most fun
at an establishment
and everybody knows it.
Well...
But that's not why you do it.
I'm about to say, what's the motivation?
Just start laughing.
Is it like I'm doing it
to show off or I'm doing
it because I'm uninhibited?
There's two very different things.
It's much better to be the laugher
than being the person judging the laugher.
Yeah, nobody in Key West
is gonna judge you for it.
That's right, and that's the
beautiful thing about it.
There are places to laugh like that
and there are places not to.
So anyway, I do, I recommend Key West.
Sounds like it.
Do I have a, is it my rec in general?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think I can just give
you the go to Key West rec.
I mean, you know, that's
just not something
that everybody's in a position to do, so.
You may regret it.
But I do highly recommend it
while it's still, you know, above water.
But I will say, completely unrelated,
I had never read, so
this is my official rec,
never read anything from Andy Weir.
You know, the guy who wrote "The Martian."
I've seen the movie.
But then he has this new
book, "Project Hail Mary."
And I don't believe I could have read it,
like physically read it.
I listened to it.
The only reason I'm saying that
is because it's so technical
and he gets into the
science in a lot of detail,
where I think that my attention span,
I would have had trouble sticking with it,
but it was perfect to listen to
'cause I am interested in all that stuff.
But great story.
I mean, I was like, "Oh,
this is why everybody talks
about how great this is."
It kind of reminded me,
'cause you talked about the
"The Three-Body Problem"
which I think he recommended at one point
way back in the day,
but just like a sort of
futuristic interstellar,
you know, story
that gets into some really
interesting scientific details,
but also just happens to be
a great story about humanity
and the things beyond humanity.
You finished it?
Yeah, oh yeah.
Yeah, I definitely, I finished
it and was like, "Oh wow."
If you like Andy Weir,
you know, he hasn't
written that much stuff,
so it's just like, if you like Andy Weir,
what else can you read?
And I'm trying to find some things
and so far I have not been satisfied.
Okay, well.
But I think I might have to
read that "Three-Body Problem"
since you talked about it.
You might have to, I'd listen
to that too if I were you
for the same reasons.
Okay, all right. And Weir, not weird.
All right, next week,
I'm gonna talk to you about
my excapades, escapades.
Excapades.
My escapades in Big Sur
and on the coastline of
California with my wife.
So come on back, y'all.
In the meantime, #EarBiscuits.
Be a part of the conversation,
weigh in on Key West
and any of the stuff
that Rhett talked about.
Please do.
Bye-bye.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.